why
so as we pick up with the death of
Wolverine issue number two we meet up
with a man named Koro who is meeting
with Wolverine now Korra doesn't know
this is Wolverine he simply is just
aware that someone has come to mad
rapport and is seeking an audience with
Viper not only that this person
apparently has something they wish to
sell and as something that Viper would
most likely want to buy now initially
Cora was playing hardball here he's
doing a business tactics I guess and of
course he's telling Wolverine that it's
a little strange that he would show up
here and he would offer to sell
something to Viper
but of course Wolverine says that if
Viper is not interested in buying and
perhaps he'll sell it to mystique she
sees it she is apparently the person
that's running mad rapport these days
although Viper is looking to move up in
the world and so what a-what Koro does
is he responds to Wolverine when he's
surprised to learn that Wolverine
actually has this item with him and so
what he does is he asked to see it he
asked to examine this item and so
Wolverine pulls this item out which is
revealed to be a helmet belonging to
Tony Stark more specifically it's the
mark 9 helmet and what Koro tells us is
that the only advancements are the only
I guess technology regarding the Iron
Man suit that exists beyond this helmet
is in the mind of Tony Stark indicating
the Tony Stark just probably hasn't
created it yet so this is about as
advanced as we can get at the moment and
so what he does is at the I guess at the
request of Koro Wolverine hands the
helmet over and Caro actually puts the
helmet on in order to verify its
authenticity because as Kouros States a
lot of things are counterfeited in
Madhupur
and this may very well be one of them
and so when he puts the helmet on he
begins analyzing the end nightclub
looking around and among the people that
we see here we of course see Christoph
Barnard who is the adopted son of Victor
Von Doom but we also see that that
mystique is actually in the club that
she's dressed as a man and it's
presumably just interacting with various
other people or dancing with other
people but again what this does is it
gives Kuro the verification that he
wants it gives Kuro the verification
that he's looking for
but again Wolverine also says that he
didn't come here
deal with an underling and he came here
for the purpose of dealing with Viper
directly and that if she wants to buy
this item then Viper is going to have to
grant him an audience so that she can
buy it directly and so kori agrees and
takes Wolverine before before Viper now
what happens is once they actually get
to Viper once Kuro introduces this
person although he doesn't specify a
name we realized that Viper knows
immediately who Wolverine is and tell
Korra tells quarrel that he's stupid for
bringing Wolverine in here that
Wolverine himself is far more valuable
than the helmet of Tony Stark and so
again what a Wolverine says that he
apologizes tokoro that he had basically
tricked him and that both him and Viper
have assorted history which of course
Wolverine touches on briefly by
mentioning if the two of them had
previously been married
and so what Viper does is she dispatches
her henchmen to try to I take down
Wolverine to try to eliminate him but of
course Wolverine is easily able to
overpower her henchmen at which point of
course Viper begins out talking with
Wolverine and she asked him how it was
that he was able to gain the helmet of
Tony Stark to gain this Iron Man helmet
and Wolverine says a Tony Stark it owed
him one and that there's most likely
people out there that owe him for their
very lives let alone the people that are
out there trying to kill him and so what
he says is that the word on the street
is the Viper had put a contract out for
him and that there were other ways to
try to get ahold of Wolverine if this is
what she was looking to do but again
Viper says that she was not the one that
put the contract out what had happened
is that someone had come to her and
someone had told her that they want
Wolverine alive
and so because Viper is well-versed in
dealing with criminals with with knowing
criminals and operating with criminals
she had basically subcontracted this out
she had put the word out that she was
looking for Wolverine alive and that
anybody that brought Wolverine to her
would be paid a hefty sum of money now
what this most likely means and it
stands to reason given the very nature
of this sort of society is that when she
subcontracted this out she would offer a
fraction of the money that was being
offered to her but she would offer
enough that it would entice anybody
indicating that the amount of money that
was being offered was a huge amount and
so again what she tells Wolverine is
that she'll give Wolverine the
information that he wants that she'll
tell him who the client is
but only if she's able only if he's able
to defeat her pet or her dog as she
refers to which of course is revealed to
us as being saber-tooth now the question
that that Wolverine asked to Sabretooth
is how it was that he had got mixed up
with Viper why it is that he's
associated with Viper and he had said
that the vibe that Viper had basically
bailed him out when he had gotten in
trouble but the problem here is that she
had basically bitten him she had
poisoned him and when she did she had
kept him on a short leash saying that as
long as she is that as long as
Sabretooth did what she told him to do
that she would basically give him an
antidote each day which which I guess
ensures that that Sabretooth follows her
and does what it is that he's supposed
to do and so again what she says is that
she wants one of them to die she wants
either Wolverine to die or she wants
Sabretooth to die but whichever one
survives we'll find out what it is they
want to know or get whatever it is they
want and so what happens is Wolverine
and Sabretooth begin engaging in
conflict one another now Wolverine grabs
the helmet of Tony Stark and throws it
Adam at Sabretooth and the helmet of
course explodes but Sabretooth says this
isn't enough this isn't going to be able
to do enough to kill someone who has a
healing factor but again Wolverine is
able to presumably overpower Sabretooth
or the very least it appears that way
but we see before the conflict escalates
any further that Lady Deathstrike
appears out of nowhere and throws
Sabretooth off now Lady Deathstrike is
actually preparing to deal the killing
blow to to Sabretooth here she's
preparing to to kill him but Wolverine
steps in and says no a Wolverine says
that he's chained up like a dog and that
if he is going to die it's going to be
under an honor under an honorable
circumstance it's not going to be as
though he was simply taken out into the
backyard and shot and so what happens is
Lady Deathstrike led Sabretooth go until
Sabretooth that the only reason why he's
living now is because Wolverine had
requested it so in addition it seems as
the Wolverine maybe has a change of
heart here not in the sense of killing
Sabretooth but in the sense of his view
of Sabretooth of course Sabretooth says
that Wolverine is just like him and the
only reason why he had a Lady
Deathstrike spare Sabretooth is because
a Wolverine wants to kill Sabretooth in
his own way but of course as we know
Wolverine is most likely going to die
here so his chance of killing
a tooth is non-existent indicating that
he had basically just spared sabertooths
life for no other reason than because
it's the right thing to do or because
it's the nice thing to do and so what he
does is he starts talking with Lady
Deathstrike of course at this point
viper had already taken off she had
bailed as soon as Lady Deathstrike had
appeared and so Wolverine begins the
process of bandaging himself up he
begins going through and trying to heal
his wound to recover his wounds and
again Lady Deathstrike takes notice of
this but at the same time she also says
that whoever it was it put the contract
out on Wolverine had also put the
contract out on Lady Deathstrike herself
as well as others like them indicating
that perhaps this person's not
necessarily going after Wolverine but
going after what it is it will rain
possesses whether it be as adamantium
whether it be his supposed healing
factor which of course we know at this
point doesn't exist anymore and so again
we see that his Lady Deathstrike
realizes that Wolverine doesn't have a
healing factor that he's basically no
longer of any use to her there's really
nothing that he can do to help her out
here but then she has a change of heart
and realizing that perhaps she can trade
Wolverines life for her own and she
tells Wolverine there's honor in this
that that had been sacrificing his life
for Lady Deathstrike would be something
that that would be remembered on that
there would be an honorable thing to do
and so again before Lady Deathstrike is
actually able to do even a tackle over
an ordeal a killing blow we realized
that someone speaks up from behind her
and this person is revealed to be Kitty
Pryde the person that Wolverine had been
talking to on the phone with that being
said we're going to go ahead and bring
this video to an end I hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys later peace but we
had one more important sound we wanted
you to hear